[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
chronique et de reportage sur public
scena 90 minutes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos invités experts
c'est le 17e jour de guerre entre Israël
et le Hamas les bombardements continuent
de viser Gaza mais les 360000 hommes
massés par T n'ont toujours pas reçu
l'ordre d'envahir l'enclave
palestinienne en attendant l'aide
humanitaire a pu passer une nouvelle
fois aujourd'hui et le balai
diplomatique continue dans la région où
le président français est attendu demain
un conflit au Proche-Orient qui offre à
Vladimir Poutine une opportunité de
renforcer ses liens avec les pays arabes
tout en restant un allié d'Israël le
président russe qui s'est affiché la
semaine dernière à Pékin en profite pour
vanter dans ce contexte ses liens avec
la Chine tous les conflits mondiaux sont
des menaces communes qui renforcent la
coopération entre la Russie et la Chine
pourquoi la guerre contre laamas peut
favoriser Poutine dans la le contexte la
scène internationale comment la Russie
résiste à son isolement malgré 20 mois
de sanctions économiques Vladimir
Poutine peut-il jouer un rôle de
médiateur au prochaini on répond à
toutes ces question dans 45 minutes mais
d'abord Emmanuel Macron en Israël demain
après Joe Biden Richi sunac Georgia
Meloni ou encore Olaf Scholz que peut-on
attendre de la visite du président
français première réponse en image avec
Fabien RER après Joe Biden Richi sunac
ou encore Georgia Meloni c'est au tour
d'Emmanuel Macron de se rendre en Israël
en début de semaine dernière au détour
d'une conférence de presse le président
avait lui-même posé ses conditions à un
tel déplacement pour ma part je me
rendrai dans la région dès que je
considérerai que nous avons un agenda
utile et des actions très concrètes à y
conduire dès lors quels sont les
objectifs diplomatiques d'Emmanuel
Macron le chef de l'État rencontrera
Benyamin netan Atel Aviv il devrait
aussi se rendre au chevet des familles
françaises dont les membres ont été tués
dans l'attaque terroriste du Hamas ainsi
que des proches des SEP otages français
présumés nous avons aujourd'hui des
familles françaises qui sont en attente
de nouvelles de leurs proches aotage
et je crois que le le président de la
République je crois je suis sûr qu'il a
une action résolue pour obtenir la
libération
de ces otages mais le déplacement
présidentiel sera également scruté sur
la scène internationale Emmanuel Macron
devrait réaffirmer le soutien de la
France à son allié israélien tout en
s'engageant pour le respect du droit
humanitaire à Gaza après les récentes
manifestations devant des ambassades
françaises comme ici en Tunisie il
s'agit aussi de calmer la colère dans
les pays arabes c'est une visite
indispensable tous les les grands chefs
d'État S sont rendus au Premier ministre
pour afficher une solidarité avec Israël
après cette attaque terroriste et en
même temps rappeler que il n'y aura pas
de sécurité pour Israël s'il n'y a pas
une solution politique et une solution
qui devrait passer par deux états vivant
côte à côte dans la paix et la sécurité
le voyage d'Emmanuel Macron en Israël
sera enfin scruté de près en France où
le conflit israëlo-palestinien polarise
la société et la scène politique le
balai diplomatique au prochient ce sera
l'un des thèmes de notre débat j'accueil
Laurent Saim bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
ancienne correspondant en Israël et aux
États-Unis David rigouer rose bonsoir et
bienvenue chercheur à l'Intitut français
d'analyes stratégique chercheur associé
Aleris et rédacteur en chef de la revue
Orient stratégique Damien Simono bonsoir
et bienvenue à vous aussi maître de
conférence en Scien politiqu à
l'Institut national des langues et
civilisation orientale et Mathieu
croissandau bonsoir Mathieu bienvenue
éditorialiste politique Laurence sa vous
avez visionné je je ne le savais pas
avant que vousarrivier hein c'est
vraiment il y a il y a quelques minutes
que que vous m'avez prévenu vous avez
participé en en visionférence à une
comment on peut appeler ça une sorte de
conférence de presse organisée par
l'armée israélienne à partir d'images
récupérées c'est ça de l'assaut du du 7
octobre d'abord comment ont-ils récupéré
C ces images de de quelles images on
parle alors en fait on est évidemment
dans une bataille de communication de
part et d'autres et les Israéliens après
beaucoup d'hésitations ont décidé de
montrer à la presse étrangère cet
après-midi des images récupéré sur les
caméras Gopro qui étaient sur le corps
de certains terroristes du Hamas et non
seulement ils ont décidé de récupérer
ces images qu'ils ont décidé de montrer
sans être monté c'est-à-dire des images
qu'ils ont récupéré et qui sont montré
tel que la caméra GoPro l'a filmé au
moment des attaques du 7 octobre et
parallèlement à ça ils ont aussi
récupéré les images des caméras qui se
trouvaient notamment dans les voitures
les images de caméras de surveillance et
là aussi sans son il décide de montrer
de manière brute ses images qu'est-ce
qui vous frappe dans dans dans
alors on bah c'est la brutalité de
l'horreur ça ça me frappe vraiment euh
ça m'a vraiment choqué et j'ai été sur
des conflits je déteste dire que j'étais
reporter de guerre machin ça n'a aucun
sens mais j'ai quand même une petite
expérience de zones très sensibles
notamment dans cette partie du monde où
je suis allé plus de six fois j'ai
jamais vu ça et ça c'est vraiment ce
qu'on entend de la part des Israéliens
mais c'est vrai que quand on le voit en
tant que journaliste on est vraiment
confronté à une barbarie que je n'ai
jamais vu c'est-à-dire des gens qui
tuent des civils pour sans aucun mais
aucune hésitation ils viennent pour tuer
et il y a autre chose qui m'a frappé
c'est l'état d'excitation des
terroristes ils sont tous extrêmement
excités ils s'applaudissent il y a une
scène qui m'a particulièrement marqué
c'est un terroriste qui après la rêve
parti prend son téléphone portable et
appelle et on l'entend le terroriste
dire papa PAP papa j'ai tué 10 Juifs tu
dois être fier de moi je vais t'envoyer
tout sur WhatsApp il y a une autre chose
qui m'a marqué c'est par exemple un
terroriste qui arrive dans un kibibo et
il fait comme dans un jeu vidéo avec une
arme on voit très bien la caméra donc
qui est sur lui et on le voit aller à
gauche aller à droite et puis d'un seul
coup il y a un chien qui arrive et sans
aucune hésitation il AB le chien avec
deux ou trois balle et puis ensuite il
continue et là il arrive dans une maison
il y a une scène absolument déchirante
d'un père avec ces deux enfants le Père
est vraiment tué devant les deux enfants
le sang coule sur le corps des deux
enfants et les terroristes parlent aux
enfants en disant voilà et il y a un
petit qui dit mon père est mort mon père
est mort et les deux enfants couverts de
sang sont emmenés il y a des scènes
atroces je vais m'arrêter là il y a des
scènes de décapitation c'est absolument
terrible et puis il y a surtout alors de
manière journalistique les caméras de
surveillance qui étaient dans les
voitures de gens qui ont été tués par
les terroristes du Hamas et on voit de
manière très précise le nombre de gens
du Hamas qui sont là sur la route
comment ils étaient armés avec beaucoup
d'armes avec des RPG il y a quelqu'un
qui est sur une moto avec trois armes
sur son dos et on sent que l'opération
était extrêmement bien préparée et que
c'est une opération militaire
professionnalisé David rigolerose il y a
beaucoup de d'éléments évidemment vous
avez commencé à le dire on est aussi
dans une guerre informationnelle donc la
diffusion de ces images aujourd'hui euh
n'est pas d'autre mais qu'est-ce que ça
dit quand même de la préparation du
ramas et de sa façon d'opérer est-ce que
il y a une une part d'étonnement à voir
le ramas opéré comme ça dans lors de
cette attaque terroriste ah bah tout le
monde a été un peu oui surpris faut faut
le reconnaître hein c'estàd qu' un
niveau on savait que le Hamas était il
avait une branche militaire les brigad
Kassim dirigé par Mohamed Daif donc on
savait qu'il y avait une amélioration
opérationnelle mais là on on est on est
passé à quelque chose de tout à fait
différent en terme de planification
d'organisation de préméditation euh euh
c'est c'est assez assez sidérant au sens
propre du terme parce que là c'est plus
du tout le type d'opération que pouvait
mener le Hamas
euh les les années précédentes comme
avec des combats limités euh dans un
périmètre on va dire chronologique et
spatial là il y a effectivement une une
opération militaire euh très bien
préparé terre air mer donc multimodale
ce qui n'est pas ce qui n'est pas rien
on parle des des drones on parle des des
parapantes il y avait aussi des des
commandau de marine enfin donc c'est
c'est effectivement les forces spéciales
en fait de de des brigades et et on
revient alors on va pas refaire tout ce
qu'on a déjà dit depuis 15 jours mais on
se moi on vous entend dans redire ça on
se repose la question comment les
services secretéaliens ont pu passer à
côté de la préparation d'une telle
opération oui alors il il est
vraisemable qu'il y ait eu des choses
qui ont été vues et et et mal apprécié
probablement on peut on peut repenser à
ce qui s'est passé le 11 septembre he
aux États-Unis c'estàdire que ça a été
ça a été présenté comme une surprise
totale oui et non c'estàd qu'il y avait
quand même des éléments qui auraiit pu
laisser penser simplement les pièces
s'ajustaient pas les unes et les autres
les l'évaluation certaines informations
sont pas remontées au bon endroit ont
bien été évalué donc il y a il y a
probablement cet élément qui a qui a pu
jouer et puis il y a aussi la dimension
politique qui peut être posée
c'est-à-dire une vigilance qui était
déplacée on va dire décentrée et et qui
a certainement joué aussi làdessus et
juste les services secrets
internationaux dire la CIA occidentaux
ou sur place tout le monde est passé à
côté aussi bah oui ENF non moi ce qui me
frappe est pour renchérir sur tout ce
que vous dites vous avez raison il y a
sur les images que j'ai vu aujourd'hui
mais vraiment une défaillance de la
sécurité israélienne qu'on voit
c'est-à-dire que quand vous voyez sur le
bord d'une route en Israël 15 à 20
hommes puissamment armés qui sont à un
arrêt de bus et qui marchent
tranquillement et qui sont là et qui
attendent les voitures pour massacrer
des civil à l'intérieur des voitures et
il ne se passe rien lorsqu'on connaît
Israël et qu'on sait quand même qu'on
est à la frontière de Gaza et cetera on
se dit que ça dans plus tard il y aura
une enquête sur la défaillance de la
sécurité un mot de réponse sur les
autres services secrets Paris que
c'était la question de de Mathieu après
je vous donne la parole dam oui il y a
eu probablement une une sousévaluation
de toute façon c'est c'est clair mais
mais au premier r desquel effectivement
les services israéliens qui sont quand
même réputés pour leur leur fiabilité et
leur qualité de d'estimation des
situations donc là il y aura un
diagnosticque qui sera qui sera fait à
postériori c'est pas le moment n'est pas
choisi évidemment maintenant dam Damien
Simono pardon vous interrompe si on se
projette le là on est en train de
décrire ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'on le fait mais le fait que vous ayez
visionné ces images justifie qu'on le
fasse de nouveau euh on est en train de
décrire une opération particulièrement
bien préparée est-ce qu'on peut imaginer
que le Hamas est prévu la phase suivante
c'est-à-dire ce qui va se passer là dans
dans les sans doute dans les prochains
jours c'estàdire la la la ripost desal
de l'armée israélienne en effet en
Israël on s'interroge sur ce délai de
mise en œuvre d'une incursion terrestre
qui est annoncée les Israéliens sont
quand même habitués à du combat dans des
zones très denses très urbaines là ils
s'attendent peut-être à des des des des
des des des mines antichar ils
s'attendent à des choses des guerres de
tunnel quelque part mais en effet on a
du mal à penser que le Hamas n'est pas
anticipé l'incursion terrestre et
notamment l'ancrage régional de ce qui
peut se passer à Gaza ce qui peut
expliquer aussi les tensions peut-être
entre les Américains et c'est pour ça
que Jo Biden on en parlait tout à
l'heure a peut-être aussi essayer de
tempérer ce que Benjamin netanahou veut
faire donc on sent bien qu'au sin de
l'appareil diplomatique et militaire
israélien il y a des interrogations
peut-être sur la stratégie à mener h
alors on va écouter pour parler de cette
offensive terrestre effectivement 17e
jour de de guerre elle n'a pas encore
été déclenchée je vous propose un un
extrait
de l'intervention je cherchais le mot du
ministre de la Défense détruire le
ramasse il le redit il est dans une base
de l'armée de
l'air cela prendra un mois 2 mois 3 mois
et à la fin il n'y aura plus de
Hamas avant que le Hamas ne rencontre
nos blindés et notre infanterie il va
connaître les bombes de l'armée de l'air
euh David rigouerose est-ce que l'État
d'Israël peut attendre encore longtemps
avant de déclencher cette offens terr
d'A probablement pas l'offensive aurait
certainement dû avoir lieu un peu avant
mais il y a eu aussi la pression
américaine il y a eu un débat il y a un
débat aussi au sein de de salle hein et
et et et des tensions entre l'échelon
politique et l'échelon militaire hein on
voit entre justement le chef
d'état-major benamin netanahou parce que
il y a il y a les paramètres politiques
qui rentrent en jeu et qui effectivement
sont freinent freinent alors que joaf
Galand voudrait y aller maintenant et il
anticipe même d'ailleurs quelque chose
sur le front nord tout de suite il l'a
dit de manière ce qu'on vient d'entendre
c'était hier hein c'é ououais ass pe
civiline hein c'estàd qu'il est persuadé
qu'il va y avoir une deuxième séquence
avec le front nord juste est-ce qu'ils
ont défini un but de guerre un objectif
de guerre parce qu'on dit éadication du
Hamas mais ça veut dire quoi non mais
pas simplement quand on les écoute ils
ont défini un autre but de guerre et ce
qui est très frappant quand vous les
écoutez briefing après briefing que ce
soit l'armée israélienne que ce soit les
communicants parce qu'ils sont quand
même très en train de de de spiné comme
on dit dans le langage politique il y a
toujours un mot qui revient et ça c'est
ce qui me frappe depuis le début et ce
mot qui a d'ailleurs inquiète les autres
chefs d'État c'est le mot Iran ça
revient tout le temps par exemple
pendant la projection à un moment donné
ils ont arrêté la projection des vidéos
et il y a le général en charge des
opérations militaires à Gaza le général
israélien qui est venu et qui a dit aux
journalistes qui étaient présents dans
cette salle de projection n'oubliez pas
que l'Iran est derrière tout ça il
n'arrête pas de parler de l'Iran alors
après qu'est-ce que ça veut dire on ne
sait pas mais ce qui me frappe dans
cette communication israélienne c'est ce
mot Iran qui dès le premier jour revient
tout le temps et ça a été l'inquiétude
comme vous le disiez des Américains et
c'est toujours l'inquiétude des
Américains les Américains sont
extrêmement inquiet de ce qui peut se
passer Damien Simono qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire de de de la préparation de
l'expérience peut-être des soldats
israéliens de ces combats urbains parce
que c'est de la guerria urbaine oui ben
il y a il y a par exemple au sein de
l'armée israélienne une école
stratégique qui a renouvelé justement la
guerre urbne au début des années 2000
l'ancien chef d'état-major coravi
justement faisait partie de cette
école-elà c'est un savoir on se base
notamment aussi sur des écrivains comme
de leuse comme d'autres pour justement
réinventer la guerre pour ne pas passer
par les rues mais passer par les murs et
combattre à travers les murs ça a été
terrorisé par des architectes notamment
israélien et il y a eu ces expériences
là en 2002 à naplelouse notamment dans
la vieille ville de naplelous au moment
de la seconde Intifada ils en ont fait
aussi l'expérience en 2006 à leur dépend
puisque le hzbolla dans les zones
urbaines libanaises utilisait aussi
cette tactique donc on peut supposer que
l'armée israélienne est prête à ce genre
de combat mais là encore on on est dans
une rivalité mimétique l'armée
israélienne va s'adapter à ce qu'elle
trouve en face et est-ce quelle quelle
tactique le Hamas va mettre en œuvre et
quel degré de
régionalisation va s'insérer cette cette
inurion terrestre moi je rappelle qu'en
2014 au moment où les Israéliens entrent
dans Gaza il y a eu des batailles au
corps à corps terribl entre les forces
spéciales israéliennes et à l'époque
ramas il y avait des immeubles où tout
était piégé et les Israéliens ont subi
de nombreuses pertes à ce moment-là donc
vous avez tout à fait raison à mon sens
de dire que cette bataille de Gaza elle
a été prévue et anticipée et c'est
peut-être pour cela qu'on est dans cette
attente de cette offensive terrestre et
si tu puis juste rajouter un petit truc
pour aller dans tout à l'heure sur la
tension entre l'échelon militaire et
politique on vient de vivre en Israël
avant cette guerre c'était il y a 2
semaines he des tensions énormes entre
Benyamin Nanou et l'appareil militaire
et notamment tous ces réservistes de
l'armée qui n'ont pas voulu rapporter
pour leur Séan de réserve pour s'opposer
à la réforme judiciaire que voulait
mettre en œuvre benjamin netanou donc on
hérite d'une période et d'ailleurs les
services de renseignement israélien et
certains hautgadés avaient averti en
engage un peu voilé netanahou en disant
nous diminuons la la capacité de
préparation de l'État israélien en
mettant en œuvre cette réforme donc il y
a déjà en fait une situation de tension
quand même au plus haut N ouais David
rerose euh à quel point le le Hamas est
déjà affaibli par les frappes aériennes
ça fait 17 jours de frappe là bah vu vu
le la surprise stratégique qui a
constitué son opération le degré de on
va dire de d'atrition sur le sur le
mouvement pour l'instant il faut être
prudent hein parce que j'imagine qu'il a
il a il a prévu hein anticipé la reposte
aérienne Isra on peut penser qu'il y
aura sûrement des surprises tactiques au
moins au minimum euh sur l'opération
israélienne alors chacun se jauge de
toute façon mais ils ont vraement encore
encore de la marge ce qui me fait penser
ça c'est qu' on voit que malgré les
frappes successives le pilonnage ils
parviennent encore à tirer des roquettes
ce qui est quand même ce qui ne va pas
de soi compte tenu du du contexte
militaire qui qui prévaut aujourd'hui
ils ont une autre arme et ça c'est
nouveau ils ont les otages ils ont plus
de 222 otages qui sont à Gaza on n
jamais connu
et c'est un élément extrêmement
important non seulement pour Israël mais
pour tous les pays concernés qui ont des
hôel bien sûr si vous voulez bien on y
reviendra un tout petit peu plus tard
dans ce débat un dernier mot sur
peut-être si on se projette là encore
Damien Simono est-ce qu'il y a un débat
politique au sein d'Israël sur ce que
pourrait devenir Gaza après cette
opération militaire alors il y a
plusieurs voix qui s'expriment là-dessus
parce que si on s'entient qu' règlement
enfin qu'au discours militaire c'est
éliminer le Hamas mais il y a des voies
qui sont venu de l'ambassadeur Israël
aux Nations Unies qui disait nous
n'allons pas réoccuper Gaza il y a des
ministres qui ont appelé des membres du
likun à une Agba 2 donc il vont jusqu'à
l'expulsion population PAL l'ex l'exil
de 1948 qui a mis entre 600000 et 800000
Palestiniens vers les territoires
occupés vers enfin ce qui est maintenant
les territoir occupés vers Gaza vers le
Liban et cetera et il y a aussi des
ministres d'extrême droite qui sont
membres du gouvernement la ministre des
implantations notamment qui en mars
dernier se félicitait d'une décision de
justice où elle disait qu' pouvait dans
le futur recoloniser Gaza c'est-à-dire
réimplanter des civils israéliens
là-dedans donc la question elle est là
en fait la question elle est politique
et on pour en parler peut-être sur la
positionnement de la France là-dessus il
y a quand même une interrogation sur ce
que les Israéliens veulent faire de
cette demande de Gaza hein en terme
politique et là il y a quand même
énormément de scénarios possibles
remettre l'Autorité palestinienne ça
semble extrêmement difficile l'Égypte et
la Jordanie notamment le roi de Jordanie
a expressément manifester le fait qu'il
ne voulait pas de réfugiés palestiniens
parce que pour lui les civils doivent
rester à Gaza et puis les Israéliens ont
parlit aussi d'augmenter la buffer zone
donc cette espèce de
Zone Interdite le long de la frontière
voilà donc il y a plusieurs scénarios
politiques possibles là on peine à voir
à comprendre voilà allez on ouvre un
chapitre diplomatique dans ce débat
Mathieu on va évidemment se projeter
vers la visite du président français
demain en Israël après il faut bien dire
la plupart de ses homologues occidentaux
oui plus de 2 semaines surtout aussi
après les attaques meurtrières du Hamas
hein voilà donc le chef de l'État qui
sera en Israël alors il a beaucoup
hésité pour des raisons de politique
extérieure si on résume il l'a résumé
lui-même il veut que que sa visite soit
utile entre guillemets et qu' a un
agenda utile autr dit que ça débouche
sur quelque chose de concret que ce soit
pour les intérêts français là-bas et
notamment le sort des otages ou que ce
soit pour le sort politique de la région
ce qui est évidemment beaucoup plus
compliqué et il a hésité aussi pour des
raisons de politique intérieure d'une
certaine façon c'est il s'est dit savez
toujours cette peur au sommet de l'État
d'importer le conflit Israël au
palestinien sur notre territoire et
c'était évidemment risqué mais résultat
il est aujourd'hui un des derniers oui à
faire le déplacement car B diplomatique
on l'a rappelé tout à l'heure a commencé
la semaine dernière avec le chancellier
allemand Olaf Scholz hein qui de toute
façon l'Allemagne on le sait depuis la
Seconde Guerre mondiale il est allé par
réflexe parce qu'ils sont toujours du
côté d'Israël ils le disent depuis
depuis cette époque- là ensuite Joe
Biden qui lui a lié indéfectible il y a
été aussi alors on verra ce qu'il dit
officiellement puis on verra peut-être
aussi ce qui s'est passé officieusement
et puis il y a eu le lendemain c'était
Richy sunac le le le Britannique suivi
par Georgia Meloni qui a fait le voyage
aussi tel vive aujourd'hui c'était Marc
routeux le Néerlandais et donc Emmanuel
Macron alors chacun y a mis des
sensibilités particulières mais en gros
tous ont témoigner leur soutien et leur
solidarité au peuple israélien tous ont
appelé on dit qu'Israël avait le droit
de se défendre et puis tous ontppelé
aussi au respect du droit humanitaire
international et à épargner les civils
et Emmanuel Macron peut pas vraiment
dire autre chose ben non évidemment sa
parole elle est quand même attendu mais
on devrait pas avoir d'énormes surprises
Catherine Colona d'ailleurs a rappelé la
position française au sommet du K
weekend droit d'Israël à se défendre
protection des populations civiles ça
c'est pour l'immédiat j'allais dire et
puis pour la suite droit de la sécurité
droit à la sécurité pour Israël et droit
à un état pour les Palestiniens ce qui
est la position française en fait quand
on va sur place il faut obtenir des
résultats sur le plan humanitaire c'est
plutôt Joe Biden qui les a obtenu en
desserrant le verrou de Rafa pour le
pour le corridor humanitaire même s'il y
a pas beaucoup de convois quand même qui
sont passés sur le plan diplomatique et
notamment des discussions avec les
leaders régionaux là pour le coup Joe
Biden avait fait choublanc mais c'était
pas de sa faute il y avait eu cette
explosion à l'hôpital de Gaza la veille
le miniommet avait été annulé en
Jordanie mais d'autres ont fait un peu
le job hein ri Suna qui a entamé une
tournée régionale jusqu'en Arabie
Saoudite même Georgia Meloni er s'est
entretenu avec Marmoud Abbas le le
leader du fata sonans grand succès
évidemment pour le moment mais donc va
pas y avoir de nouveauté à attendre de
la part d'Emmanuel Macron qui lui
évidemment va parler aotage évidemment
va aussi parler de de des suites
possible pour la région et là
franchement c'est pour l'instant c'est
très très limité il y a eu un coup de
fil hier soir enfin une conférence
téléphonique entre Biden Justin trudau
le Canadien Olaf Scholz l'allemand
George melloni l'italienne et
richichiunac et Emmanuel Macron alors
les six chefs d'État ont discuté desès
derniers développement de la crise ils
ont rappelé encore une fois protection
des populations civiles et puis droit
légitimes à Israël à se défendre et puis
la suite je v dire comment ils en ont
parlé un communiqué dans lequel il
s'engage à poursuivre une coordination
diplomatique étroite notamment avec les
principaux partenaires de la région afin
d'éviter que le conflit ne s'étend et
afin de préserver la la stabilité au
Moyen-Orient et devrait en faveur d'une
solution politique et d'une paix durable
HM c'est à peu près tout évidemment on
en est loin ouais évidemment David
rigolerose pourquoi a-t-il tellement
hésité ti Emmanuel Macron d'près vous
bah quand quand il a il avait
évoqué sa venue potentielle en disant
que ça serait en fonction des
discussions je cite hein que je poursuit
j'envisagerai simplement je veux pouvoir
venir en pour obtenir les choses utiles
donc il y a un point d'interrogation sur
les l dit choses utiles parce
qu'effectivement c'était assez flou et
se sont succédés bah tous ces tous ces h
donc cétait difficile de de pas le faire
du tout mais on sent bien qu'il y avait
des hésitations et qui tenait pour parti
probablement aux difficultés d'obtenir
des choses utiles sur place certainement
même si aujourd'hui il envisage par la
voix de de ses de négocier une trêble
humanitaire c'est d'ailleurs le le aussi
le projet de Joseph Borel mais d'une
certaine manière ça se noit dans dans
j'allais dire dans la voie diplomatie
européenne et puis évidemment il y a la
question centrale otages puisque il y a
le précédent des libération américaines
et il voudrait il voudrait pouvoir
puisqu'il y a une demi-douzaine de
compatriotes il voudrait pouvoir
effectivement il a été apostrophé par
les familles donc mais ça va être très
compliqué ça va être très compliqué et
sinon son autre positionnement c'est de
dire qu'il faut absolument empêcher une
logique escalatoire mais euh mais on
voit mal comment à lui seul il serait en
mesure de justement de sursoir à cette
logique escalatoire faute de dissuasion
euh crédiible juste une chose la
relation personnelle Macron netanahou ça
joue elle en est où Damien Simono elle
est plutôt froide on va dire d'ailleurs
Emmanuel Macron c'est était davantage en
phase avec Yair lapide donc le le
dirigeant maintenant de l'opposition qui
n'a pas rejoint le gouvernement d'unité
nationale ni le cabinet de guerre
d'Emmanuel de Benjamin netanahou en tout
cas on sent qu'il y a une forme de de
distance moi j'ai un peu envie de dire
que la israëlpestine pour Emmanuel
Macron c'est une hypothèse que je fais
c'est pas vraiment sa tasse de thé je
crois véritablement que Emmanuel Macron
il s'intéresse à la région quand on
parle des accords d'Abraham quand on
parle des rapprochements Émirats arabes
unis Israël justement parce qu'il peut y
avoir des intérêts aussi commerciaux
Emmanuel Macron a sans doute une
fascination pour la nation start-up
entre guillemets que que constitue
Israël mais je crois pas que notre notre
voix et l'héritage qu'il a eu d'essayer
d'avoir cet équilibre entre une position
proalestinienne et proisraélienne il
arrive vraiment à la tenir si on reprend
le remake de cette visite de l'éise ça
fait un petit moment que cet équilibre
là il a un peu été rompu ou en tout cas
déstabilisé heinter à la président
Nicolas S oui mais je pense qu'il a pas
nécessairement envie en fait de peser
plus que ça donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
l'impression quand même d'avoir une
diplomatie qui est plutôt de l'ordre du
discursive qui est plutôt de l'ordre des
images plutôt qu'elle n'obtient
véritablement quelque chose cette
hypothèse là que j'ai envie de faire
Liban voilà oui dans la région également
oui mais en fait la la France la la voix
française elle pèse quoi de moins en
moins dans cette région du monde Dav je
vais vous redonner la parole après elle
est pour partie un un peu relativement
dévaluée c'est-à-dire qu' évolution sur
les les dernières années c'est le le
dernier coup d'é class c'est celui de
Jac Chirac Jérusalem en 96 après on a le
sentiment à tort ou a raison
queeffectivement la voix de la France
c'est un peu diluée dans une logique
soit européenne soit plus globale et
c'est très difficile d'affirmer une
spécificité comme ça peut être le cas
précédemment et ça l' d'autant moins que
on la marge en terme de moyens est
également réduite et on l'a vu c'est
pour ça que j'évoqué la question du
Liban parce qu'il il y a eu une geste
présidentielle en allant au Liban après
l'explosion du port en mettant en
demeure les les ses interlocuteurs
libanais de trouver une solution et puis
euh bah a la réalité fait que rien ne
s'est réellement passé depuis ouis
Laurence Saim voulait intervenir al j'ai
une analyse un peu différente moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on est dans sous nos
yeux la construction d'une coalition et
que ils sont bien embêtés dans la
communication d'abord que Joe Biden
réunit s parle à 5 présidents un
dimanche c'est pas dans les habitudes de
Joe Biden je rappelle que c'est un
président qui aime beaucoup passer du
temps dans ses weekends donc l'heure est
grave pour que le dimanche il soit en
vidéophone avec ces cinq chefs d'État
quand vous voyez la composition de
l'équipe de Joe Biden qui va voir
netaniaahou alors là c'est je suis
tombée par terre il y a 18 personnes et
c'est pas l'assistant qui est là pour
lui mettre le promeur c'est toute la
Maison Blanche en charge de toutes les
relations internationales des cris
sérieuse s'est déplacé en Israël pour
parler aux Israéliens on ne sait
absolument rien de ce qui s'est dit et
moi les communiqués que je vois passer
il y a rien dans les communiqués vous
l'avez très justement c'est du blabla et
on les voit très bien les communiquants
dire mais qu'est-ce vous attendez la
réponse en fait vous ditz il y a une
stratégie commune qui se met en place
etose ils ont parlé à netaniaahou à mon
sens ils lui ont dit porte fermée voilà
ce que nous on pense et netaniaahou
comment il a réagi on ne sait pas les
Israéliens ont une idée très précise de
ce qu'ils veulent faire il y a à mon
avis de grands désaccords sur ce que
netanahou veut faire ce que les
Américains veulent les Américains sont
inquiets ils ont positionné des Marines
ils ont positionné deux portes-avion il
n'arrête pas de dire publiquement et
l'il d'ustin qui est le secrétaire
d'État au Pentagone l'a dit hier à nos
confrères de ABC qu'ils sont très
inquiets et que tout peut arriver et on
est quand même dans de l'inquiétude et
des gens qui essayent d'aller voir les
Israéliens en leur disant attention il y
a effectivement le problème des otages
mais ne faites pas n'importe quoi alors
les otages justement elle sera
évidemment euh cette question abordé par
Emmanuel Macron demain en Israël
quelques images hier soir à Paris une
centaine de personnes qui ont collé dans
la ville 4000 affiches on va voir ces
images avec les photos et les noms des
des otages euh parmi les les
participants parmi celles et ceux qui
collaient ces ces affiches la trésorière
de l'Union des étudiants juifs de France
l'écoute on pourra jamais assez le crier
jamais assez le le dire jamais assez
montrer leur visage on veut vraiment pas
qu'il soit oublié et c'est vrai que
souvent sur les réseaux sociaux on voit
beaucoup de messages de haine beaucoup
de messages de
désinformation qui sont très très
néfastes et qui propagent aussi beaucoup
beaucoup la haine et beaucoup les fake
news c'est pour ça aussi c'est pour
lutter contre contre cette
désinformation contre ces fake news
qu'on fait cela et par parce
qu'évidemment il faut continuer à
demander leur libération et ne jamais
les oublier David rigol rose le le la
concertation dont parlait Laurence sa
mais on imagine qu'il y a beaucoup
d'éléments qui qui rentrent en ligne de
compte quand si chefs d'états
occidentaux voilà se réunissent comme ça
en visioconférence la question des
otages elle est certainement en première
priorité c'estàd qu'on a un chef d'État
américain qui a réussi à obtenir la
libération de deux de ses compatriotes
on imagine Emmanuel Macron peut-être peu
d'espoir que ce soit la même chose vous
voyez ce que je veux dire ça met la
pression pardon c'est un peu trivial ce
que je dis mais ça met la pression sur
tous les chefs d'État qui vont là-bas ah
benah clairement mais de toute façon
c'est une situation totalement inédite
on on s'est jamais retrouvé
finalement dans dans une configuration
où il y a autant de nationalités qui ont
été prises en otage binationaux ou pas
mais même des étrangers en
l'occurrence de dans un contexte de de
de guerre ouverte et on a jamais eu
autant de morts côté français par une
attaque terroriste depuis l'attentat de
Nice
décs avec une demizaine de compatriotes
qui sont porté disparu alors il y a une
otage qui a été identifié effectivement
qui en appelle justement au président
Macron donc mais c'est vrai pour
d'autres nationalités alors il se trouve
que les deux premières à avoir été
libéré sont des Américaines ce qui est
pas surprenant parce que Biden en l'a
dit il a dit c'était son vraiment
c'était son son problème central alors
ce qui est surprenant sur la libération
des otages américaines c'est on n pas de
détail mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on
sait simplement qu'ils ont négocié avec
le Qatar ça veut dire que le Qatar est
un pays qui peut se faire entendre et il
y a aussi autre chose moi qui m'a
beaucoup surpris sur les otages
américaines libéré c'est qu'elles ont
l'air plutôt en forme alors que on voit
quand même sur des vidéos qu'il y a
d'autres otages qui sont beaucoup moins
en forme dans des tunnels mais donc ça
veut dire que il y a quand même ce poids
des otages qui va jouer et des pays
extérieurs à Israël et à Hamas qui sont
là pour être les intermédiaires et là
Joe Biden qui remercie le Qatar m'a
particulièrement étonné d'ailleurs on
consacrera une une partie de l'émission
demain la seconde partie de notre
émission sur le rôle l'influence le le
poids politique cette positionnement un
peu à la croix des chemins du du Qatar à
la fois partenaire économique des
Américains et puis et puis soutien du du
Hamas on on l'a déjà dit sur ce
plateau américain est bien sûr s
militaire vous avez raison économique et
et militaire donc on va pas ouvrir un
chapitre Qatar parce que ce sera
vraiment le thème l'un des thèmes de
l'ém
demain mais sur ce effectivement cette
multitude de de
nationalités représenté par parmi les
les otage et les morts de l'opération
terroriste du du Hamas Damien Simono
est-ce que c'est aussi une des
explications je reviens presque à la
première partie du débat au au entre
guillemets au délais pris par l'armée
israélienne pour pour lancer cette
offensive th je sais pas je pense moi je
suis plutôt vraiment du côté des
dissensions au sein de l'armée et des
tempérances avec les États-Unis et je
crois qu'il y a aussi au sein de la
société israélienne je veux le rappeler
également il y a eu des manifestations
là où se tenait justement à Tel Aviv
devant le quartier général de l'armée le
fameux boulevard capelan où il y a eu
toutes ces manifestations contre le
gouvernement ces derniers mois là il y a
eu samedi et le samedi d'avant un une
manifestation de famille d'otage
justement qui commence à mettre la
pression et qui commence justement à
insister sur cet enjeu-l donc il va y
avoir aussi une pression de l'intérieur
de l'État et la société israélienne
quand même arrive également à faire
presscieux sur des enjeux de défense à
différents moments moi je serais plutôt
sur quelques ch qui alur dans fait de
l'identification d'essayer de tracer les
téléphones voir où sont justement les
les otages mais plutôt des dissensions
sur la stratégie adopter la coordination
avec les Américains et les Alliés plus
généralement voilà et sur les otages
faut quand même rappeler un poid
personnel cap Benjamin netaniaou qui est
an TB vous vous souvenez il y avait eu
cette prise d'otage à TB avec cet avion
d'airfrance qui avait été détourné par
des pirates un commando se réclamant de
Septembre noir et il y avait eu une
opération surprise qui est très
importante dans la société israélienne
pour libérer les otages avec le frère de
netanou qui était en charge de cette
opération qui a été tué sur place et ça
a marqué quand vous connaissez netanahou
quand vous parlez avec lui et cetera
c'est quelque chose qu'il a profondément
marqué parce qu' vous nous dites quoi
que ça peut retenir ça je pense qu'il y
a un côté non il y a un côté il y a un
côté psychologique personnel de gérer
une situation d'otage comme son frère
qui a dû gérer en TB et en mais ça a été
d'une certaine manière une victoire très
symbolique pour les Israéliens nous ne
céderons pas nous allons rechercher les
nôtres et même s'il y a de la CE il
parlait comme ça nous allons quand même
les sortir c'était en Ouganda avec
amindada qui était là ils se sont
déguisés pour approcher l'avion où
étaient les otages avec un israélien qui
s'était mis du cage sur le visage pour
jouer à mindada pour détourner
l'attention du commando Septembre noir
c'était le frère de netanahou qui était
en charge de cette opé qui a été tué
parce que les terroristes de Septembre
noir ont rosté nthanahou a été
profondément marqué non pas par
évidemment la mort de son frère mais
aussi par est-ce qu'il fallait y aller
en TB parce qu'il y avait un risque que
tous les otages soient sacrifiés ils
avaient décidé d'y aller et je suis sûr
que ça pèse sur naniaahou évidemment
revivre rentendre cette histoire dans le
contexte actuel ça ça nous semble très
intéressant on va ouvrir un dernier
chapitre dans ce débat consacré à au
soutien américain à Israël notamment le
soutien militaire je propose à Steve
Jourdain de nous rej joindre tout de
suite sur ce plateau bonsoir Steve
bienvenue à vous les États-Unis qui
c'est vraiment le cas de le dire font un
retour en force dans la région oui on en
parle assez peu en France mais les
États-Unis sont en train de déployer la
plus grande armada militaire dans la
région depuis la guerre contre daesh
c'était en 2014 on va voir le dernier
communiqué qui a été publié samedi par
le Pentagone les Américains montent
encore d'un cran dans leur dispositif
suite à à des discussions approfondies
avec le président Biden concernant la
récente escalade de l'Iran et de ses
alliés au MO Moyen-Orient les États-Unis
s'apprêtent à prendre des mesures pour
soutenir les efforts de dissuasion dans
la région et augmenter la protection des
forces américaines et contribuer à la
défense d'Israël concrètement Thomas le
Pentagone ordonne le redéplo
redéploiement d'un porte-avion
supplémentaire dans la région le Dwight
isenower mais aussi la mise enir de
troupes supplémentaires et l'envoie d'un
système de défense antimissile à haute
altitude ainsi que des batteries de
missile patriote supplémentairire alors
ça nous dit pas forcément grandchose à
nous mais les experts considèent qu'il
s'agit tout simplement des armes les
plus puissantes disponibles actuellement
sur le marché pour lutter contre les
attaques de missilees donc un
renforcement de de cet arsenal militaire
et ça s'ajoute au matériel qui a déjà
été envoyé après les attaques
terroristes du 7 octobre oui Washington
avait déjà annoncé l'envoi de 2000
soldats et marines supplémentaire dans
la région et surtout le déploiement du
Gérald fort le plus grand porte-avion du
monde à son bord 4500 soldats et jusqu'à
80 avions à hélicoptère le G forord est
accompagné d'un croiseur et de quatre
navires destroyurs pour vous vous donner
une idée he Thomas ce seul groupe
aéronaval correspond à l'ensemble de la
capacité de l'armée de l'air française à
cela il faut ajouter le déploiement
d'avons de chasse américains en Jordanie
mais aussi des avions de transport de
troupe on parle de 15 au total rien
qu'en Jordanie il a enfin le soutien
militaire apporté directement à Israël
62 avion cargo ont atterri sur le tarmac
de TelAviv le 7 depuis le 7 octobre il
s'agit tout simplement du plus gros
déploiement de la sorte depuis la guerre
du Kipour en 1973 alors certains de ces
navires viennent d'arriver dans la
région est-ce que ils ont déjà d'une
certaine façon pris part au conflit oui
jeudi dernier 19 octobre au moins trois
missiles et près d'une vingtaine de
drones ont été tirés depuis le Yémen
direction Israël et probablement la
ville d'élad dans le sud de pays c'est
en tout cas ce que nous dit le Pentagone
qui a intercepté ses missiles lancé par
les les milices chit outil ces milices
qui sont soutenu financé armé par l'Iran
écoutez et bien le porteparole du
Pentagone ces missiles et ses drones ont
été lancés depuis le Yémen en direction
du nord le long de la mer Rouge
potentiellement vers des cibles en
Israël notre réponse défensive est celle
que nous aurions adopté pour toute menac
similair dans la région concernant nos
intérêts et nos partenaires il se peut
que l'attaque se poursuive tout faire
pour que cette attaque ne se poursuiv
pas tout faire pour éviter un
embrasement régional c'est l'objectif de
cet impressionnant déploiement des
Américains dans la région merci Steve
pour tout t ces détail Dav rig le mot le
plus important peut-être c'est le mot
dissuision à la base oui quand ils ont
commencé à envoyer d'abord le Gerald
fort c'était un message de dissuasion
mais là on passe un ça va au-delà le
curseur monte considérablement euh
notamment avec les le système TAD qui
est un système antibalistique hein donc
c'est la prévision éventuellement d'un
conflit élargi qui mobiliserait des
types d'armes euh à l'échelle régionale
et donc d'où l'inquiétude américaine
conement des missileiraniens
potentiellement des missiles iraniens en
tout cas du hbola au minimum voire voire
iranien oui euh et donc il y a il y a
une grande inquiétude là effectivement
puisque c'est un niveau de d'engagement
enfin de déploiement qui est on oublie
d'ailleurs avec les les pores-avions il
y a des sous-marins nucléaires he qui
les accompagnent donc c'est c'est c'est
massif comme déploiement et c'est pas
pour c'est pas pour la galerie
évidemment mais dans dans le communiqué
qu'on vient de voir samedi le mot Iran
est quand même écrit et quand vous savez
la prudence des américain dans la
période actuelle écrire le mot Iran dans
un communiqué venant du Pentagone ça
veut dire que encore et toujours il y a
la menace il faut dire les choses tes
qu'elles sont d'un affrontement direct
avec l'Iran et là on est vraiment dans
une imprévisibilité totale et l'autre
chose moi que je note c'est dans le
déploiement des forces américaines il y
a quand même 32 avions cargo qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire les avions cargo ça
permet aussi d'acheminer des armes mais
aussi d'évacuer très vite les
ressortissants américains qui seraient
en Israël il y a beaucoup d'Américains
qui on la double nationalité les
pores-avions et les avions cargo
permettent si jamais à un moment donné
la situation sans venim de faire une
évacuation massive des Américains et il
y a déjà l'ambassade américaine basée à
Beyrouth qui a qui avait lancé un
avertissement en disant attention si
jamais vous devez quitter le pays il
faudra passer par haa en direction de
Chipre éventuellement et on pourra venir
vous récupérer tenez-vous prêt Damien
Simono ce risque d'embrasement régional
moi j'aime pas être inutilement
anxiogène pour le téléspectateur mais on
peut pas enfin voilà c'est quand même
une des hypothèses et une réalité
possible il est dans l'inconscient moi
non plus j'aime pas être nécessairement
moi je veux juste rappeler également ce
qu'a dit Joe Biden quand il est revenu
d'Israël dans un entretien il me semble
depuis le le bureau oval de la Maison
Blanche où il a lié en fait en demandant
au Congrès justement des rallonge
militaire de budget militaire la
situation en Ukraine et la situation en
Israël ça c'est aussi intéressant parce
que ça trahit aussi quelque part leur
conception géopolitique moi je pense en
tant qu'analyste que on n'est pas
véritablement nécessairement dans les
mêmes théâtres d'opération avec les
mêmes problématiqu
pas du tout je crois qu'encore il y a
une très forte importance des enjeux
locaux des affrontements entre
Israéliens et Palestiniens mais c'est
intéressant que dans leur vision
géopolitique il y a le lien entre la
Russie et l'Iran qui peut-être se fait
sans doute se fait encore une hypothèse
très forte voilà mais c'est à préciser
c'est aussi une manière de raisonner moi
je voudrais comme on est quand même sur
Public Sénat je voudrais rappeler que
Joe Biden il a eu un moment
extraordinaire dimanche et tout le monde
le dit c'est-à-dire que l'adresse à la
nation d'un seul coup ce président
américain où tout le monde critiquait où
tout le monde disait il est trop vieux
et cetera il est apparu en sage de la
nation et même nos confrères de Fox News
ont salué la performance de Joe Biden
c'est un président qui est apaisé
apaisant dans une crise absolument
terrible une crise anxiogène comme vous
le dites et c'est aussi important de
voir que ce président américain là il
est solide dans quel cadre il le fait
c'est un message qui était prévu on peut
rappeler c'est pas du tout prévu et vous
avez une très bonne question Thomas vous
savez vous adressz lorsque vous êtes
président américain depuis le bu EUR
aual et ça s'adresse ça s'appelle
adresse à la Nation ça veut dire que
l'heure est très grave c'est pas a il y
a des codes dans la politique américaine
vous pouvez vous adresser depuis de
istrom ou par exemple Barack Obama
arrive pour dire on a tué Ben Laden mais
là c'est un message à la nation
américaine c'est on peut pas faire plus
important en terme de communication
politique qu'un président américain qui
est assis derrière son bureau dans le
bureau oval et qui s'adresse au pays
tout entier au nom de l'unité dans un
moment très sérieux pour la démocratie
David ggoleros qui sont les modérateurs
ceux qui parmi les pays arabes les pays
de la région ce qui appuie sur le frein
en quelque sorte pour éviter cette cet
embrasement tous les pays arabes
appuient sur le frein ils espèrent
justement que ça ne dégénère pas parce
que de toute façon il ils seront en
première loge donc la question elle est
elle est plutôt qui appuie dans l'autre
sens c'est ça le vrai problème et on
voit bien qu'il y a les proxis qui
commencent à s'agiter les les proxis les
outils au Yémen puisque av all onou des
mandatair proiraniens c'est vrai euh le
hzbola qui a émis des messages menaçant
les les milices chit pro-iraniennes en
Irak qui ont d'ailleurs attaqué la base
américaine d'alassad ce qui est pas
anodin et et puis la menace que ça peut
représenter pour les bases américaines
notamment la 5e flotte he qui est à
Bahrain et puis l'usncom qui est au
Qatar mais juste en face de l'Iran donc
ça traduit certainement une une
perception accrue de l'inquiétude des
États-Unis qui ont peur de d'être
entraîner alors qu'ils souhaitaent
justement essayer de d'apaiser le
l'environnement régional et qu' se
rendent compte que ils sont obligé de
mettre tout leur poids justement pour
peser un dernier mot Laurence Saï il y a
une question effectivement de politique
intérieure américaine parce que c'est
mené deux guerres de front bon peut-être
que que l'armée que l'armée américaine a
les moyens de le faire mais mais encore
faut-il que le Congrès suive le
président Biden voà c'est exactement ça
il y a une crise politique majeure c'est
jamais arrivé il y a pour le moment
personne ne se met d'accord pour élire
le président de la Chambre des
Représentants c'est un peu comme s'il y
avait plus de président de l'Assemblée
nationale dans le système américain il
faut voter des lois et là si Joe Biden
veut faire voter une loi de financement
d'aide supplémentaire à la fois
l'Ukraine et à la fois en Israël et bien
il faut que le Sénat et la Chambre des
représentants qui doivent fonctionner
puisse voter ça il y a le budget qui
risque d'être paralysé dans 15 jours on
est dans une crise parlementaire très
importante aux États-Unis qui a aussi
son importance dans cette situation
internationale tendue merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat et à bientôt sur sur Public Sénat